Here's everything I make in an afternoon
as a mom who was just traveling for the past three weeks
and needs to get back into her healthy routine.
Part 2. After straining my chicken bone broth,
I threw together a wild salmon salad for lunch
using ingredients in my pantry.
You'll never find tuna in my pantry
because it's high in mercury and something I try to avoid.
I whipped up a homemade Mayo yogurt
using two orange yolks for my backyard chickens,
extra virgin olive oil, Dijon,
half a lemon for my tree, and mineral rich sea salt.
Mayo is a super food when you make it yourself
rather than the store bought trash that's got seed oils.
I still have some pickled green peaches from last year's harvest,
so I added these in. When the broth was chilled,
I scooped off the nutrient dense fat
and stored that for later cooking uses.
I remove the fat from my broth so that we don't overdose on it.
I like to know how much fat I'm adding into a meal
and this is the best way to do it.
When it was time to get dinner started,
I harvested some zucchini from my garden
and then created a casserole by adding shredded chicken, quinoa,
gelatinous broth, tomato sauce,
and raw cheese to a Dutch oven.
This is a really easy meal to throw together for a family
as it doesn't require much skill or thought.
Dinner baked for over an Hour when the keto was set.
Next time I'll give myself a little more time for the bake.
But I started a bit late. Before bed,
I fed my sourdough starter
so it would be ready to bake bread in the morning.